quando eu fui chamado pra falar aqui
hoje e responder essa pergunta que o
candidato eu vou querer deixar os meus
filhos é a resposta que vinha
insistentemente na minha cabeça era
também o tema do primeiro é de xira rj
que hoje vai organizar aqui há quatro
anos atrás em 2012
encontros é naquela época ajudando a
construir esse evento estava nos
primeiros períodos da faculdade é e eu
descobrir que nós somos mais de 60 mil
alunos de graduação e pós graduação da
universidade
mais de 3.700 professores descobri que
temos dezenas de bibliotecas com mais de
3 milhões de livros e periódicos
espalhados por elas que mais de 4 mil
trabalhos são apresentados todo ano a
jornada de iniciação científica que hoje
em dia se inscrevendo se é difícil mas
no passado os alunos tinham que
acamparam universidade para conseguir
uma vaga nas filipinas descobrir que foi
na praia vermelha no teatro de arena é
na década de 60 que a bossa nova foi
apresentada para o mundo com um show de
joão gilberto e foi na mesma praia
vermelha na mesma década de 60 que o
exército brasileiro ea polícia militar
cercou o campus invadiu o campo e
agrediu 600 alunos que estavam ali
reunidos entre outras coisas pelo
direito de encontrar naquele último
golpe no último golpe
é eu já ouvi falar de encontros eu
comecei a pensar qual foi a primeira vez
que eu entendi que viviam universidade
estudava na universidade desencontrada é
é ainda o primeiro período tinha acabado
de conhecer camilo que foi tornar uma
grande amiga minha faculdade ea gente
numa dessas conversas de corredor se
deparou com as questão uma questão
simbólica quer é o fato da gente estudar
na escola de comunicação social da ufrj
e não conversar não dialogar não trocar
com as pessoas que estudam na escola de
belas artes onde tem um curso de
comunicação visual da ufrj e essa
distância entre a comunicação social e
comunicação visual ea falta de
comunicação entre esses dois cursos se
mobilizavam perfeitamente o que a gente
entendia como desencontros
eu então fui na minha timeline do
facebook e resolvi tawa quais foram os
encontros que marcaram nesses últimos
cinco anos desde que eu entrei na
universidade ea primeira coisa que eu
achei foi essa foto aí um pouco antes de
eu começar o trabalho de passar no
vestibular
tive o privilégio de poder juntar o
economista é a minha família tinha feito
caso o chefe da universidade privada é
pra fazer uma viagem para a europa de
dois meses e por acaso tinha caído para
quem aderir naquela situação
privilegiada no dia 25 de maio de 2011
em barcelona onde encontrei milhares de
jovens desempregados sofrendo na ponta
crise do capitalismo e da falta de
representação é e reunidos com o
objetivo de reconstruir a democracia e
construir uma democracia real já
e naquele momento entendi que a
faculdade de comunicação que eu ia fazer
não seria só uma faculdade de
comunicação e se a faculdade de ativismo
e comunicação
o ta passando assim é foi foi mais ou
menos isso aconteceu eu voltei para o
brasil é em outubro de 2011 quando acaba
meu primeiro período da faculdade é eu
comecei a construir junto com alguns
amigos é ocupa rio era uma campainha
urbana na cinelândia uma praça de tantos
encontros históricos que atende o
chamado global dos indignados de espanha
que pediam para que as pessoas ocupassem
os braços pelo mundo e se encontrassem
para conversar sobre o sistema que a
gente está vivendo e e aí eu comecei a
freqüentar esse espaço ea matar muitas
aulas no primeiro período da faculdade
nesse lugar
meu pai está aí hoje é muito acima
também foi mal o que falar o que vocês é
nas eu comecei a matar quantas aulas e
vários de meus amigos na época falavam
cara você tá doido etapa já começou a
faculdade matando aula praça e aí eu
entendi que eu podia não está tão errado
assim quando alguns professores
começaram a marcar as aulas dele dentro
da praça
e aí eu entendi que talvez tivesse um
movimento que não fosse tão regrada e
que a gente pudesse ocupar esse espaço
e foi no ocupa rio também que eu conheci
a as pessoas que criaram o meu rio que
foi a organização que nasceu entre um
voluntário e hoje eu ajudo é a coordenar
contrariando as estatísticas da geração
y é que pulam de galho em galho matou
mais de quatro anos no mesmo emprego e
no meu rio ajudei meu filho pra quem não
conhece uma rede de mobilização que
reúne mais ou menos 200 mil pessoas que
já participaram online e offline de
ajuste das ações para construir um rio
de janeiro mais inclusivo democrático e
participativo
e foi pelo meu rio que eu vivi talvez
alguns encontros mais marcantes da minha
vida como o encontro com os pais e mães
professores e alunos da escola municipal
friedenreich
não sei também que quem conhece a
história dessa escola mas ela em 2002
era a quarta melhor escola do rio uma
das melhores escolas do país um projeto
pedagógico incrível é uma das poucas
escolas que atendia os alunos com
necessidades especiais
e essa escola é ela é
foi nesses paz nessas mães nesses alunos
que a gente encontrou uma força que a
gente não imaginava que a gente iria
encontrar durante um ano e meio de
mobilização de 2012 é foram aulas de
engajamento e de organização que essas
crianças e seus pais e os professores
deram pra gente aula da manu que
organizou o próprio abaixo-assinado dela
no caderno dela pra apoiar a campanha
online que a gente estava fazendo aula
da nicole que está no meu ombro nessa
foto é que editava os vi com 10 12 anos
em editar os vídeos dos colegas dela que
eles gravavam em apoio à campanha e
nesse dia quando a gente estava saindo
da da audiência pública sobre a
privatização do maracanã que a gente
levou as crianças através da companhia
de financiamento coletivo na internet
ela me ajudou também a organizar os as
crianças estavam meio perdido entre
índios atletas torcidas organizadas
uma coisa maluca se encontra em um
desses encontros bem marcante que viver
é e as aulas de mobilização dos
ativistas todos que viveram em torno
dessa causa até conquistar a vitória e
fazer cuidar do pai sérgio cabral é em
todo o time deles é desistir em demolir
essa escola que era a quarta melhor
escola é do rio de janeiro que a
construção de um estacionamento para a
copa do mundo
enquanto isso nossa rj é a gente envia
uma das maiores greves que a gente viveu
nos últimos três de 14 anos e eu
considero foram 102 dias de greve e eu
posso dizer com tranqüilidade que essa
foi uma boa greve e eu falo que ela foi
uma boa greve porque ela foi uma greve
de encontros ela foi dessa greve surgiu
ocupam ser aqui no fundão e surgiu o
grave groove da praia vermelha
dois coletivos que usavam arte como
forma de se expressar e expressar as
demandas e posicionamentos que aquela
greve tinha
entre alunos professores é por acaso um
coletivo da escola de comunicação ou
escolher um outro coletivo daqui da fao
da aeba que não conversaram muito na
época mas estavam fazendo coisas boas é
interessante
ao mesmo tempo é durante essa greve
enquanto a gente está organizando o
partido da candidata em 2012
a gente também ocupou junto com vários
coletivos de movimentos sociais
o canecão que é um espaço que é público
que a ufrj é e realizou shows e eventos
e trocas
lá dentro eu nunca tinha vivido em
nenhum outro lugar é o canecão que é
esse espaço de tantos encontros da
cidade e considerado um patrimônio da
cidade
mas tão abandonada pelos desencontros da
justiça e dos processos burocráticos que
a gente tem hoje nas decisões políticas
a gente chega a junho de 2013 é talvez
um dos momentos onde eu encontrei nas
ruas opiniões tão diferente é e no mesmo
espaço na mesma na mesma rua na mesma
avenida
pessoas que pensavam um projeto de país
de extremos apostas estavam ali reunido
e certamente um dos encontros com maior
potencialidade complexidade que eu pude
estar presente e não era um só a
diferença de opiniões políticas vieram
também diferenças sobre como agir e como
a gente vai conquistar essas mudanças
e foi ali naquele momento que eu entendi
que aquela vontade de fazer uma
faculdade de ativismo comunicação que eu
tive lá na espanha é faria fazia todo o
sentido para mim eu estava fazendo todo
o sentido para mim e foi aí que a gente
criou em laboratório de ativismo
comunicação da ufrj
o laboratório feito por alunos criado
com alunos como a érika eo cadu estão
aqui o que é um canal e danilo te
ajudaram a tirar do papel e apoiado e
assinado por professores como marie que
falou agora pouco e fez isso acontecer o
laboratório ativismo em comunicação ele
foi um encontro pra mim que me fez
encontrar com o lugar de estar no lugar
de professor facilitador de um grupo de
alunos que eram os alunos mais novos
chegavam na época e é muito doido
porque é não só as dificuldade e
complexidade de organizar um
conhecimento e passar a ele mas também a
dificuldade e complexidade de ta falando
para um grupo de pessoas
enquanto algumas estão no celular como
vocês puder olhar um pouquinho de
atenção brincadeira não tem ninguém
conseguiu ver vocês é essa e eu não
podia deixar de fazer esse momento de
lembrança dos encontros marcantes em
falar dos encontros de curso que eu fui
que muita gente aqui deve achar que é só
um pretexto para um monte de jovens
viajar de graça e conhecer as cachaças
do interior do país mas na verdade foi
uma oportunidade para a gente de
compartilhar encontrar com o juventude é
do brasil inteiro de várias cidades de
vários estados
é um pouco do que a gente está vivendo
ali na comunicação e no ativismo e no
laboratório destiny gente esse também é
e aí nesse momento eu aprendi a
importância é que é a o fomento aos
encontros enquanto política pública como
como a universidade pode ser um espaço
que somente esse tipo de encontro
inclusive entre universidades e para
além desses muros para o encontro
nacional de comunicação a gente também é
foi uma vez é o rafa e eu quero pra mim
o encontro regional de estudantes de
arquitetura mais uma vez a galera da fao
ebba e na verdade é que a gente não
tinha ido tanto por uma coisa mais
organizado e está vendo mas quando essa
for mesmo passar as férias
a onu diz que não sabe a capital
nacional do forró mas a gente acabou
encontrando a um espaço de troca e
conversa com os futuros arquitetos do
brasil é sobre cidades que universidade
que país que mundo a gente quer
construir e o quanto a gente pode
influenciar nessas construções para que
sejam universidades cidades países mundo
feito para as pessoas tanto se falou
nesse palco que hoje foram muitos
encontros que eu vivi nesses últimos
quatro anos só foram alguns mais
marcante é e aí para vir aqui falar algo
diferente do que normalmente fala eu
conversei com algumas pessoas
é tentando chegar à resposta para
algumas dessas perguntas qual o
significado da palavra
o encontro como criar bons encontros e
como tornar a universidade um lugar -
encontrado é a primeira coisa que eu
entendi e por isso fiz aquelas perguntas
no início é que se a gente não circula
pela universidade que a gente estuda
dificilmente a gente vai conhecer os
incentivos fantásticas que nela habitam
assim como a gente não circulam na
cidade em que a gente vive
a gente fica para sempre no eixo centro
zona sul o fundão é a gente nunca vai
conseguir encontrar as potencialidades
que existem dentro desse espaço que se
chama rio de janeiro de verdade no rio
de janeiro dez novelas
a gente se conhece mais pela pj
explorasse mais a gente conhecer o
carona aí que o aplicativo de caronas
para a comunidade acadêmica da
universidade a gente conhecer é o sentai
que é um encontro entre técnicos
administrativos para compartilhar os
conhecimentos experiências e
aprendizados da própria universidade
a gente podia conhecer o arquipélago tem
um jornal que está sendo desenvolvido
pela escola de comunicação da ufrj para
diminuir essa distância
a gente conheceu os alunos contadores de
histórias que promovem encontros com
crianças e pessoas que precisam dia
carinho atenção e alguém que tenha tempo
para encontrar com elas ou as dezenas de
iniciativas e coletivos que existem na
universidade para quem é de humanas
branquinha de exatas
é como a liga de robótica da ufrj que
tem cinco iniciativas dentro da própria
liga ou como o grupo comunidade disse
que um grupo de dança para a comunidade
acadêmica da universidade é talvez a
gente conhecesse mais o colégio
brasileiro de altos estudos que fica na
antiga casa do estudante universitário
mas que hoje é muito pouco frequentado
por estudantes ou talvez a gente
conhecesse mais as rádios livres que
existem dentro de nós estamos é nessas
conversas
eu consegui formula então rápido o
significado do que é encontro a partir
de uma construção coletiva e de
diferentes respostas que houve é
encontros são como mágica que acontece
entre duas pessoas
usam mais pessoas ou entre uma pessoa e
este mês um eles podem ser físicos
é como o encontro da mocidade espírita
que acontece durante o carnaval e que o
yuri que é um dos melhores amigos da
universidade
me lembrou que existe enquanto esta
aconteceu o encontro é tão potente como
carnaval também aconteceu no outro
encontro tem uma outra proposta é e ao
mesmo tempo tem a mesma potência
uma outra potência ou os encontros
virtuais como os encontros que a gente
tem no grupo já recebe da família é hoje
a gente diminui a distância deles com
quem tá longe com que a gente não pode
estar todos os dias
enquanto isso o momento de compartilhar
idéias valores e propósitos e emoções é
e onde está o contato muitas vezes com
diferentes e que agentes eles tanto
evita aperto
nessas conversas eu tentei perguntar pra
trás pessoas quais são os ingredientes
para um bom encontro para construir um
bom encontro é ouvir palavras como
empatia que uma vez houve uma
significativa empatia que é não é você
só se colocar no lugar do outro mas você
se colocar no lugar do outro
vestindo os calçados dele é então
entendendo como é estar naquele lugar e
com aquelas condições é generosidade
interesse escuta objetivo tempo diálogo
aprendizagem diversidade e respeito e
pegando as duas palavrinhas poderia
ficar até para fazer um teste sobre cada
uma dessas palavras e enfim se aprofunda
uma monografia
mas o grafite está fazendo uma tem que
focar nela e orientador e também mas eu
peguei duas palavras é só para fazer uma
rápida provocação
se a gente quer manter na universidade a
diversidade que a gente conquistou com é
tantas políticas com algumas primeiras
políticas públicas de inclusão foram
feitos nos últimos anos eu acho que a
gente quer
espero que a gente todo mundo aqui
queira vamos debater sobre isso eu acho
que a gente tem
respeitar as diferenças e as
necessidades que estão por trás dessa
diversidade é também nessas conversas
com vários dentro dessas pessoas eu
entendi é e ficou mais claro que se a
gente não respeitar as necessidades que
essa nova juventude que entram na
universidade é tem a gente não vai
conseguir com que eles permaneçam na
universidade com que eles terminem os
cursos é eu estou falando de um
alojamento que seja seguro para todas e
todos
estou falando de um bandejão em cada
campus para que sejam têm que comer é na
cidade um preço do rio real é e eu estou
falando de mobilidade pela cidade ônibus
em circulação e passe livre o que quer
que seja uma política que permita que
essa juventude
aproveite toda sua potência e se
encontre mais nesses espaços
enquanto ela está na universidade
enquanto ela tem tempo pra pensar tempo
para criar tempo para construir e por
último eu queria compartilhar três
tarefas que eu acho que são só três
vezes em outras mas que eu resumiria
dessa vez quando concluir essa o desenho
dessa palestra que são tenham
curiosidade é tenham curiosidade para
explorar para entender o que acontece no
corredor ao lado do campus button as
salas conversa com as pessoas tirem suas
idéias do papel e como ninguém olha para
o mundo mesmo que significa colocar a
idéia ainda com fase de idéia no grupo
da turma pra ver se outra pessoa
compartilhar aquela ideia e quer chegar
junto pra ajudar a tirá-lo do papel e
ajuda a compartilhar as idéias dos
outros como as idéias que estão sendo
colocadas aqui hoje então entre vocês
nas redes
eis obrigado
[Aplausos]